this my take on the Francis situation
I'd love to get your thoughts on this
because of his outcome with Tyson Fury
now is the Joshua fight mma's on the
back bur I to be honest I don't think he
ever fights MMA again I don't know why
he would with the paydays he's getting
with you know with with Fury with Joshua
he he nailed it you know congratulations
to Francis I mean know the whole world
was were Skeptics and and uh you know he
proved everyone wrong and and so
congratulations to him you know he's
making history it was a high risk High
reward strategy and and and it worked
out beautifully I mean like I said you
got it given his life story of of of
working the minds you know in in
Cameroon all the way to where he is
today living on the streets in Paris
homeless like you just I mean there's
nothing you just his his life should be
a movie